okay this is something really special
for everybody today over the last
24 hours fox news has become a nexus an
epicenter almost like a central
clearinghouse
of election disinformation and what
makes it all the funnier is that on one
hand donald trump is furious with fox
news
because their so-called news side admits
and accepts that joe biden won the
election uh donald trump is mad at fox
news for calling arizona for joe biden
so as i told you yesterday trump instead
of tweeting fox news content
has been tweeting a lot of news max
content which is sort of like a low rent
fox news
on the other hand if you tune into the
nighttime uh
fox news programs the so-called opinion
shows although
you know the difference between fox news
and opinion at this point is is pretty
blurry
the nighttime shows on fox continue to
pretend
as a matter of fact that this election
was stolen by joe biden
they are bringing on every last grifter
that they can find
and we're going to look at some examples
and i what i the
the framing i want you to keep in mind
as you watch this is
when people in other countries see this
they think we're out of our minds okay
this is crazy that this is going on on
one of the three major cable networks in
the united states and i am aware that
watching this stuff is not great for
your brain and
um to to make a really serious point
i'm gonna play short clips because this
stuff is crazy and it's really bad for
you but
remember many americans get their news
exclusively from fox news they see this
and they see no alternative to it was
stolen
and they think it's serious so let's
start with donald trump's press
secretary kaylee mckennany
almost a meme at this point holding up
pieces of
paper we don't know what the hell they
are as proof of fraud
did sean uh we keep hearing the drum
beat of where is the evidence
right here sean 234 pages of sworn
affidavits these are a defiant and
principled kaylee mckennony holds up a
ream
a ream of paper here is republican
congressman matt gates recently
recovered from coronavirus he's the guy
who
laughed off coronavirus by wearing a gas
mask on the house floor back in
might have been march or something like
that he says
he has sources guys and the sources are
telling him really really bad things
well in washington it is even worse than
your reporting my sources are telling me
that part of the biden transition plan
would be making permanent these
coronavirus changes to the voting
process
now i have to tell you i actually hope
matt gates
is is correct matt gates is saying
oh no joe biden might try to make it
easier to vote by mail
forever not just when there's a pandemic
i hope biden does do that what this
election has proven
is when you expand vote by mail
it doesn't cause fraud it leads to
voting
that's what happens when you expand vote
by mail we should have expanded vote by
mail
forever as well as expanded early voting
i hope matt gates is right in what he's
saying
here's sean hannity wrapping up
about four to five different conspiracy
theories
into a pretzel and claiming they all
prove
that of course this election was stolen
from joe biden
of lies and conspiracies theories the
russia hoax hillary's dirty dossier
fisa abuse lying to a fisa court spying
on a presidential candidate and a
president
fake polls fake news fake everything and
then here is secretary of state
mike pompeo showing up to talk about
this election as if it's not over and as
if donald trump might still win
proud of the work that the entire team
that the president has had for my four
years has accomplished
i'm hopeful we'll have more time to
continue to work to keep americans safe
hopefully we'll have more time to keep
americans safe trump lost
dude what are you talking about and of
course mike pompeo also made a statement
to
press yesterday that there will be a
smooth transition
into a second trump administration we
covered that early
we don't know if mike uh if mike pompeo
really believes this stuff
or if he feels obligated to say this
stuff we don't know it's bad either way
and then here's rnc chairwoman rana
mcdaniel claiming that the media have
stolen the truth by not reporting
on their completely baseless
voter fraud claims and the media
right now by refusing to report on this
is stealing our faith in the election
process
tell the story talk about the people who
are being disenfranchised
people across this country deserve to
have election integrity faith in our
election system
and believe that there is election
integrity and that's why the rnc is
going to pursue this to the very end we
can never
let this happen again and lastly ted
cruz was on
and he actually ted cruz hilariously
sort of stumbled onto the truth about
this situation take a listen
one of the frustrating things as a
citizen you see all these tweets going
back and forth you see allegations if
this happened that happens
it's hard to know it's hard for anyone
to know all right is this true what's
true i
the only way to know is we have a legal
process we have state courts we have
federal courts
that can hear legal claims and and right
now
it is incumbent on the trump campaign's
lawyers to go in
and prove their case in court to lay out
evidence to lay out evidence of
illegally cast votes to lay out evidence
of what was done right what was done
wrong and when the process is over
we're going to know the result but we
need to let the process play out
and and much of the mainstream media
doesn't want to let us do that so
ted cruz is actually hear me out okay
ted cruz is actually right
there is a process for adjudicating
these claims and step one of the process
is you have to present evidence to
courts
where ted cruz is wrong is that the
media doesn't
want that to happen the reality is
courts
keep looking at the claims of fraud and
they're finding them completely without
merit so the process doesn't continue
the media is not stopping the process
the media is asking questions like
do you have specific evidence of illegal
or fraudulent votes
and when that question was put to for
example kaylee mckinnon two days ago
rnc chairwoman ronna mcdaniel two days
ago they said a lot
but they didn't say yes we have actual
evidence of specific illegal or
fraudulent votes
and that's why this isn't moving forward
in courts
it's not because the media is
interfering
but the complaints being brought to
court
are being found to lack merit and so
they aren't going forward but
again this is how fox news creates an
alternate reality
you tell your audience everybody else is
lying to you
everybody else is biased to the left to
encourage
people to discount or even ideally not
watch
anything other than fox news you fill
the fox news evening echo chamber
with laura ingram had a so-called
witness last night who refused to be
identified it was like a blacked out
shadow
beyond parody after they spent four
years saying any anonymous source isn't
okay
they're putting up witnesses that are
blacked out in shadow
they're making claims that the media
don't allow this to move forward
and if you only get your news from fox
news you end up believing this stuff
it's
i've used the term mind virus several
times lately
trumpism is a mind virus the fox news
narrative if it infects you
is also a mind virus and uh we
we can't just write them off because
they vote i get it the instinct is you
laugh it off and you move on but
we can't because they do vote this
episode is sponsored by blue chew one of
the things i make a priority on the show
is not to perpetuate stigma for things
that don't deserve it we've talked about
mental health we've talked about many
things where we should all just be
respectful adults period and we would be
better off
and blue chew can increase performance
and give you that extra confidence you
may be looking for
bluetooth.com blue like the color blue
is the first chewable with the same fda
approved ingredient
as in viagra and cialis it can be taken
day or night even on a full stomach
since it's chewable
blue chew is prescribed online by
licensed
doctors you don't have to go to a
doctor's office you don't have to wait
in line at a pharmacy it ships
right to your door in a discrete package
they're made in the usa
and since bluetooth prepares and ships
direct
it's cheaper than a pharmacy and best of
all
no more awkwardness we've got a special
deal for our viewers and listeners go to
bluechew.com
get your first shipment free when you
use our promo code pacman that's
p-a-k-m-a-n
pages five dollars shipping that's blue
chew.com promo code pacman to try it
totally free
bluechu is the better cheaper faster
choice
and we thank them for sponsoring the
david pakman show